imagine if
one day you looked up into the night sky
and saw mars or saturn
where the moon was supposed to be that
would sure turn our earth into an alien
world
and not just because of the new view
how would replacing the moon change the
earth's orbit
what planet could we safely replace our
moon with
and what planet would be the most
disastrous
this is what if and here's what would
happen
if another planet replaced our moon
we can thank the moon for predictable
weather
ocean currents and the circulation of
important nutrients
the moon also helps stabilize the
earth's tilt
take away the moon and the earth would
go wobbling all over the place
and it would cause what i can only
describe as
climate change on steroids
but we wouldn't just let the moon take a
day off
we would find it a replacement from
another part of our solar system
so what would happen if we swapped our
moon
with a planet that is 41 times its size
before we get to that dramatic part
let's talk about
pluto pluto wouldn't look much different
than
our current moon it would be smaller
though and
this wouldn't be good for earth that's
because
pluto's gravitational pull would be
weaker than that of the moon
earth would begin wobbling all over the
place and
it would result in dramatic climate
change
all sorts of natural disasters ruining
your day
the moon's gravitational pull is
responsible
for our daily ocean tides
because pluto is smaller than our moon
our ocean tides would become weaker
this would devastate important
ecosystems
i know all this sounds stressful but you
know what could help ease the stress
our friends and sponsors of this episode
caliper cbd
they've got a better way to consume cbd
did you know that
calipers powder was found to deliver cbd
30 times
faster than cbd oil in the first 30
minutes
that means you don't have to wait for
two hours for your cbd oil to fully
absorb
with caliper cbd you can feel calm and
less sore in just 10 minutes
and caliper cbd is completely tasteless
you can mix it with your morning coffee
it's thc free so it's totally safe to
take before work
add some to your protein shake when you
work out to make you less sore
hey we know what if can be a little
stressful to watch sometimes so
you might like to try some right now you
can try caliper cbd
risk free for 30 days and get 20
off your first order just go to
trycaliper.com
what if and use the promo code what if
if you don't love it they'll give you a
full refund
that's tricaliper.com what if
don't forget the promo code what if for
20 off your first order
okay where were we ah pluto covering for
the moon
well how about a planet that is slightly
larger than our moon mercury would look
exactly like our moon with its dark gray
surface
and asteroid craters and it's
only one and a half times the size so
its
impact on our tidal systems and climate
wouldn't be as disastrous out of
all the planets in our solar system
mercury would be the safest one to
replace our moon
but i can't say that about mars
having the red planet in our night sky
would be quite a sight
all the iron oxide on its surface would
glow red
no more white moonlight shining through
your window at night
instead everything would be bathed in an
eerie red
mars's stronger gravitational pull would
make
tsunamis smaller but it would make
normal waves massive and because
mars would create stronger tidal forces
earth's rotation would slow down the
days on earth
would become longer i hope we'd still
keep a 40-hour work week because
a 16-hour work day doesn't sound that
great
[Music]
moving on with venus in our night sky
we might never experience darkness
venus is the brightest planet in our
solar system
it would reflect 60 percent more light
than the moon
and because it's three and a half times
the size of the moon
it would force the earth into a binary
system
earth and venus would rotate
each other huh it would be
beautiful and disastrous
simulations of a binary system usually
end up with
planets colliding or merging
neptune and uranus are both ice giants
and
are similar in size a huge
portion of our sky would be taken up
with a blue green planet
only uranus would also stink horribly
no wonder this fart smelling planet got
such a name
since both uranus and neptune are
14 to 15 times the size of the moon
their impact on earth's rotation and
tidal systems
would be drastic beach houses
would have to be built up on cliffs
far enough away from the reach of
enormous waves
now seeing saturn up in the night sky
has to be my favorite
its pale yellow color and ring system
would be stunning but there would be
some complications
because saturn is so large the earth
would quickly become its moon and
if earth orbited around saturn it simply
wouldn't be the earth
as we know today
finally moving on to the big guy jupiter
at 41 times the size of the moon
you wouldn't even be able to see the
north and south poles of the gas giant
similar to the deal with saturn earth
would become jupiter's moon
only it would get worse because
jupiter is so massive the side of the
earth
that's closest to jupiter would
experience a stronger gravitational pull
than the opposite side this would
distort the shape of the earth
all this pulling apart would create
frequent volcanic eruptions and violent
earthquakes
jupiter's gravitational pull would tear
the earth
apart so enjoy the view while it lasts
this is not how i pictured my day
remind me of that time we made earth
collide with uranus
oh that was a stinky story but we'll
save that
for another what if